joining us right here is the author of
world war c lessons from the covet 19
pandemic and how to prepare for the next
one it is available wherever you get
your books on october 5th he is dr
sanjay gupta how are you sir
i am doing great rich it's uh it's
wonderful to speak to you again and yeah
i would be absolutely happy to help let
me know not just because of the oath as
a doctor just because i i'm
genuinely happy to help no i appreciate
that you're referring to uh you know uh
jason feller our sound man uh his you've
got broken back spinal it's it's yeah
it's a mess i appreciate you doing that
he's he's handled he's
although i'm concerned i'm concerned
that he's having surgery tomorrow and
he's doing his pre-op literally right
here on the show
i'll be honest with you there's that's
um i'm not a doctor nor do i play one on
tv but uh
anyway uh thank you for joining me jason
thank you for joining me here today uh i
appreciate it so um where do we stand
right now on the virus and the way
things are trending as we are sitting
here right now towards the beginning of
october dr gupta
i think there's some some positive signs
in terms of trends um but we're you know
trending
in a positive direction from a pretty
tough spot i mean you know a lot of
hospitals in the country
are are very
full right now uh you know when you look
at some of these icu's you know 30 40
some places even 50 or 60 of patients
are coveted patients that are in these
icus
so that's a lot of patients that you
know are
taking you know the bed space of what
would otherwise be elective operations
and and other things that you know
patients come to the hospital for so
there's just a
hospitals are not really
designed to have these huge sort of
standalone surge capacities so when you
suddenly add that many sick patients to
the mix it's it's it's a problem
cases seem to be coming down in some
places around the country that's good
hospitalizations are sort of high
sort of plateaued but they may be coming
down and deaths are still you know
they're still high but these are all
sort of lagging indicators
overall i'm optimistic a bit that cases
are coming down we've seen that in other
countries around the world but i sort of
think about this rich like my own
patient i mean the patient's still in
the icu
um but there's some favorable indicators
but we still got to keep a close eye on
things and when you say in your book
lessons from the covet 19 pandemic and
how to prepare for the next one what do
you mean by the next one
dr gupta what do you mean by well you
know i i i i'm
not someone who likes to to you know
create fear where there's not fear i'm
and i'm not trying to suggest that but i
think if you talk to most
most people who are infectious disease
doctors and who are viral hunters you
know virus hunters in these places they
talk about the fact that
these pathogens
such as this virus they keep making
these jumps from animals to humans
it happens all the time in the vast
majority of them are are harmless but as
you increase
the number of of jumps that happen
the possibility that one of them turns
into something
uh that is a virus that can spread
easily among humans again like this did
is higher so most people say you know we
used to think about pandemics almost in
these 50-year cycles right 1918 another
one in 1969 another one in 2019 which is
this this one
but most people most people seem to
think that we will likely experience
this again within most of our lifetime
so it's it's a little bit hard to say
but that's sort of the purpose of the
book why is it happening what can be
done about it and even if we can't stop
new pathogens from entering our lives
they don't have to turn into a pandemic
and and i think there's been a lot of
lessons heard learned here from
societies all the way to the individual
level well a difference i guess between
the previous pandemics to which you
referred dr sanjay gupta here on the
rich eisen show world war c is his new
book the lessons from the covet 19
pandemic and how to prepare for the next
one the difference between the previous
ones and this one is that in previous
ones there weren't a a a whole host of
folks putting out misinformation in a
device that you could see in the palm of
your hand instantaneously and so there
is a different way
of trying to combat things or or
swat away what might be the wrong way to
combat things how do you as a health
care professional and somebody on tv
with a platform deal with all that
it's it's it's um it's been probably the
most difficult part of this whole thing
i mean i think when you're a science
reporter you know i've been so head down
in this rich for the last two years i'm
reading
scientific papers coming from journals
all over the world i'm trying to
decipher it
i'm trying to
be able to explain it to an audience
that's not reading these journal
articles make sense of it for people
but i think you know
a good percentage of the time maybe
close to half the time
i'm also just hearing something that is
a bad piece of information
and then having to fact check that um
and sometimes you hear bad information
and you're like where did this even come
from am i missing something here
and then i have to go and start doing
all the homework taking me down these
these rabbit holes that don't amount to
anything and it ends up being a a
significant
uh you know amount of time sucked up
doing that i think you know i i have
long thought about this idea that
you know you the best way to combat
misinformation is to continue to provide
good information explain it well put it
out there in an engaging way
i think there is a difference i think
i've learned rich between misinformation
and disinformation
that's perhaps been the most surprising
thing this information's been around for
a while if you go back and even look in
1918 and which i've done historically
look at newspaper articles from that
time there was a lot of people
who were spreading this information then
as well
about the the the virus and whether or
not it was a true pandemic and was it a
hoax
uh it is much more ubiquitous now as you
point out because of social media and
everyone having a phone but it was there
before that sentiment was there before i
think what is different now it is so
strategically disinformation it's it's
designed to create distrust and chaos
and and that sort of thing which has
befuddled me like if you tell people
like if i search on my my my computer
for a new car i might start getting a
bunch of ford ads i get that they're
trying to sell me a car right
but when people are trying to get you to
not do something
that could potentially you know be
beneficial for your health
who's inspiring that they're not selling
you anything the only thing
they're selling you on is is distrust
and chaos and that's a really hard thing
to to focus on because it's it's
nebulous it's just sort of out there
with no clear source well i'm the thing
that frustrates me if i may uh dr sanjay
gupta is you know um
is
is the misinformation that i see or or
those who are seeking information let's
put it this way those who say they are
seeking information about whether or not
to get vaccinated
and
you know i i can understand people who
are not fully
um you know made available to them
that people don't have top of the
you know line health care professionals
at their beck and call that's a lot of
people who don't know who to trust they
don't have somebody that they can reach
out to
if they have questions about whether or
not to get vaccinated
right and then i sit here and i hear
star athletes who do have literally in
front of them and phone calls that can
be made to
anybody on the medical staff associated
with professional sports teams in the
country
still have questions about all this
saying that they're looking for
information so if you don't mind i'm
going to utilize my time here with you
by forwarding to you some of these star
athletes questions and have you answer
them right here on the rich eisen show
if you don't mind dr sanjay gupta and
first up is one of the best in the nba
uh bradley beal of the washington
wizards right in the nation's capital
and covet protocols kept him from
representing this country in the
olympics this is what he had to say at
media day
on monday
every player every person in this world
is going to make their own decision for
themselves um
i would like an explanation to you know
people with vaccines why are they still
getting coveted
if that's something that we are supposed
to highly be protected from like that's
funny that oh it reduces your chances of
going to the hospital
it doesn't eliminate anybody from
getting covered
right so everybody is everybody in here
vacs
i would assume right
so
you all can still get coveted
right we're less likely to die or go to
the hospital
okay but
you can still get covet
so the question the last one we're
seeing yeah but we're less likely to be
seriously uh ill or go to the hospital
is like yeah but you still get covered
so i'll give you the floor uh he would
like an explanation please dr sanjay
gupta the floor is yours
uh
the the the whole point of the vaccine
was to save people's lives reduce the
likelihood they get sick
and decrease
the transmission of the virus
it's in that order and i think when
people think about vaccines they often
think about the vaccine as a sort of
completely bulletproof vest uh
and it's not nothing is i mean there's
nothing that has that level of certainty
what i think
people sometimes don't don't realize
even when it goes talking about all
these other vaccines that the idea that
you could potentially still carry the
virus in your nose in your mouth
not likely to get sick
but but still carry it is true that is
true
that's not covered the disease that's
testing positive for coronavirus
we talked about getting coveted as he
mentioned a few times that's typically
referring to someone who actually is
getting sick
now someone who's been vaccinated
may develop symptoms those are called
these breakthrough cases some people who
have breakthrough cases may have no
symptoms or they may have significant
symptoms but usually not enough to go to
the hospital
the same person
if they got covered if they were tested
positive with the chronic and they were
not vaccinated you could basically say
the level of illness that they would
have
would be greater so someone who was sick
not somebody who's going to get into the
hospital now becomes someone who gets
admitted to the hospital someone who is
sick in the hospital but going to
recover now could be someone who dies
it's it's really that that simple you
know i think the the level of
expectation is hey
and i'm going to take the vaccine if you
can guarantee me that i'll never test
positive for the virus from here on out
that's not something that any medical
professional should say because that's
not the case but what they can tell you
is that ninety five percent of the
people in the hospitals covered right
now are unvaccinated
that should tell you something what they
should tell you is that in places that
you have high vaccination rates
hospitalization rates are
remarkably low
compared to what they were before the
vaccine death rates are remarkably low
the vaccines work they they
it's incredible a lot of people didn't
think we'd have a vaccine by this point
if ever there's some diseases for which
we don't have a vaccine we have it it
works
it's safe six billion of these shots
have gone out around the world
he should take it and he should take it
for himself
but he should also know that
if he were to test positive virus the
likelihood of him testing positive and
transmitting it would be significantly
lower because he's vaccinated so do it
for himself and do it for those around
him next one dr sanjay gupta comes from
the world of the national football
league cole beasley of the buffalo bills
in responding to
a letter uh a fine letter that the nfl
sent to one of his teammates during
training camp isaiah mckenzie because he
was not wearing a mask
he retweeted that saying don't worry
they got me too but i was wearing a mask
when i was in close contact with fully
vaxxed trainer who tested positive and
still got sent home so what's the point
of the mask anyways meanwhile i'm here
still testing negative and can't come
back make it
make sense
so he asked a question there i give you
the floor on that dr sanjay gupta so
he's asking he had an exposure to
somebody who uh was tested positive for
the virus but he's wearing a mask and
he's unvaccinated correct he would like
vaccinations he'd like to know what's
the purpose of the mask anyway if he's
wearing it around somebody who tests
positive and he's not positive what's
the point of wearing a mask is what he's
i'll
say say two things i mean you know a lot
of these are are based on this idea of
of i want a certain i want a level of
certainty when i do these things if i
wear a mask i want you to now be certain
that i am not going to spread the virus
or contracted if i take the vaccine i
want to be certain and if you don't give
me a hundred percent certainty i ain't
gonna do it
there's nothing in life that is certain
it is all about
reducing risk
so what i will say about masks is the
greatest benefit for someone like him is
in that if he has the virus
and may have no symptoms at all totally
asymptomatic feels fine let's say he has
it still
he could be spreading it
that is the biggest benefit of the math
when i wear a mask every day every week
in the operating room as a surgeon in
the or i am wearing a mask so that i
don't
inadvertently
uh contaminate the patient i'm operating
on spread something to the patient i'm
operating on it's called source control
so again when he wears a mask it does
provide him some protection but the vast
majority of the protection is for those
around him
if he's asking about the fact that a
fully vaccinated person spread the virus
to him yes it is possible it is possible
that we know that the vax the vaccine
works really well preventing that person
who spread it to him from getting sick
but it is possible they could still
carry the virus as i mentioned and
potentially spread it a lot less likely
but still possible
last one for you from major league
baseball chris sale um who will be
starting for the boston red sox this
week in a very important game against
the orioles he's missed some time this
year uh he tested uh for covert uh
positive twice now
uh in response to him not going to the
hospital each time he mentioned he's
still unvaccinated saying uh they were
checking in on me every day meaning the
healthcare professionals of the red sox
who by the way i should mention uh
helped me out when i was a breakthrough
case in the city of boston over the
summer and their
dynamite at mass general uh he said they
were checking me every day making sure i
was all right quote i work hard to
maintain a good diet and exercise
routine and i take vitamins every day so
i was prepared for this in the end
it worked out does having a good diet
and um an exercise routine and taking
vitamins is that something that would
actually be helpful in keeping you out
of the hospital and potentially having a
fatal reaction to covid
yeah
absolutely i mean it's
it's it's an important point and you
know one that i think does not get
discussed enough certainly not in the
throes of a pandemic you know what what
is the personal
uh responsibility in terms of health and
how much can that help you and keep you
out of the hospital keep you from
getting really sick
i mean we know for example in the united
states we're a country that got hit
very hard with this virus and there's
all sorts of reasons for that but one of
them is that we are generally a less
healthy nation than many other nations
around the world
heart disease diabetes obesity um
chronic kidney disease chronic lung
disease all these things were
significant risk factors and in the
united states we have some of the
highest rates in the world some of these
diseases so absolutely your personal
health can
can tremendously mitigate how
significant this disease will affect you
but but i but i also you know what sort
of strikes me is that we often times
think about this in terms of best case
scenario worst case case scenario life
or death
and there is this
middle ground here which i don't think
people fully realize you'll see a
perfectly healthy person you get coveted
and you
recover we're seeing is that a
significant percentage do have these
lingering symptoms
and it may not be as specific as yeah i
still can't smell
but it may maybe as i've talked to many
patients i need to take a two to three
hour nap every day that i never had to
do before in my life i get headaches
that i didn't see i have a pain that
just hasn't gone away a level of
inflammation in my body there's a lot
about this virus that we we still don't
know
so uh
bolstering up your own immune system
being as healthy as you can of course
and i i even get more specific
in the book about you know even your
microbiome and really understanding how
your gut health is so integral to your
immunity
we don't talk about that stuff enough
enough and i and i can you know talk a
lot more about that but the vaccine
is one of these tools again not a
perfect tool but a really good tool
toward preventing him from getting
infected preventing him from having long
haul symptoms preventing him from
getting very sick as well and and
he also would do it for himself
but also to help protect those around
him so
it's possible to do both and to have the
level of protection that we really need
to get to in this country
all right before i let you go dr sanjay
gupto um what does this virus look like
next summer next time we have a football
season what do you think this looks like
best you can crystal ball it for me
what do you think i think that we are um
we're gonna be a much better spot um you
know uh even even sooner than that rich
i mean
the thing is that what what happens
ultimately is that you know you get
about 55 of the country vaccinated
there's a lot of people who are getting
their immunity in a much tougher way
right now by getting you know infected
yes and
we're seeing the consequences that the
hospital where i work is totally for i
go and talk to the cmo and i said hey
try to curiosity if i get a car wreck on
my way here just now uh how how tough
would that have been for me to get care
here and he just kind of looked at me
he's like this is
bad
we might have to divert you to another
hospital another city past even another
state because we just don't have room
that's what's going on when you say hey
look let's just get a bunch of people
immunized through natural immunity it
does work if you have covert in the past
you probably have some immunity now to
getting it again
not perfect as you just mentioned
somebody had it twice
but
because of that natural immunity and
because 55 percent of the country or so
right now at least is vaccinated
we will have a lot of immunity i think
going into the spring of next year and
it'll help us yeah there could be a
brand new variant that sort of escapes
the immunity and that would be a problem
but if that doesn't happen then i think
we're going to sort of go the way that
things went in 1918 1919 we have now
surpassed the death rate uh from that
that terrible pandemic 100 years ago
granted the population the world was a
third of what it is today but still
we've surpassed that death rate despite
having icus and vaccines and all these
different things
um but
when we have enough immunity out there
i mean the numbers will start to go down
hospitalization rates will go down and
death rates will go down and at that
point i think as a society it'll still
always be there but we move on it's it's
coveted will be part of our lives but it
will be increasingly less consequential
part of our lives and hopefully we learn
lessons so the next pandemic as you say
that we uh we might endure that we're
ready for it and better prepared as you
write in your book world war c lessons
from the covet 19 pandemic and how to
prepare
for the next one dr gupta thank you for
the time and uh if you just want to have
any fun tell jake that uh you also agree
that die hard is not a christmas movie
and tell me what he says would you
please do that tell jake
my emotions in check when it comes to
the wolverines but you know i'll allow
myself to dream a little
oh my gosh if there's a vaccine for the
ohio state game let me know okay can you
please hey we didn't lose to ohio state
last year right that's true that is true
you take care of yourself thank you
you gotta thank that everybody check out
uh dr sanjay gupta's new book starting
on october 5th wherever you get your
books that's dr sanjay gupta on the
mercedes-benz vans phone line right here
on the rich eisen show hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here